it's been decades since little Bastian
bux dive into the neverending story but
it's a fantasy film that still resonates
with families today what's become of the
cast members still with us here's what
the cast of the neverending story is up
to now former child star Barrett Oliver
is now a photographic historian who
specializes in 19th century photographic
technology and literally wrote the book
on the so called Woodberry type printing
process of that era Oliver got his big
Hollywood break by way of playing the
curious camper Bastian bux in the
neverending story but he went on to
claim starring roles in Tim Burton's
1984 short film Frankenweenie 1985's
family sci-fi film a Darrel and Ron
Howard's cocoon along with its 1988
sequel mom I don't need to see a shrink
they're not dead all of us stepped away
from the spotlight to pursue his more
academic interests after 1989 scenes
from the class struggle in Beverly Hills
however his experience appearing in
front of the cameras has since come in
handy since he starred in the short film
about his craft cold in the usual manner
at Ray was something of a comeback kid
in the neverending story he endured the
depressing death of his horse and still
managed to battle back the forces of
existential destruction his real-life
counterparts Noah Hathaway seems to
share that resilience the actor has
returned to Hollywood after nearly 20
years away from the spotlights I'm blown
away by the response still I have 35
years later Hathaway had already made
something of a name for himself before
he became the fabled hero of the movie
his prior credits included 1978
Battlestar Galactica and his TV follow
up as well as appearances on a slew of
popular 80's programs however he quit
the business after starring in 1986 his
troll because he told the News Tribune
he quotes just wanted to drop off the
radar and be a regular human being after
his career as a child star Hathaway
worked in finance and tattoo artistry
and decided to return to the business in
2012 when he landed a role in the noir
thriller sushi girl he has since been at
work writing his own screenplays deep
Roy has had a long and fruitful career
in show business
the Kenyan born actor who played the
snail riding teeny-weenie in the
neverending story might actually be
better known for his part and other TV
and film roles like mr. soggy bottom and
big fish
order on Palumbo's and tim burton's
Charlie and the Chocolate Factory
although Roy was almost a decade into
his career before he starred in a
neverending story it was one of his
first big film roles German actor Tilo
Bruckner would hardly be recognizable to
those who saw him in the neverending
story since so much makeup work went
into becoming his character than my
table
however pruner has been acting in films
and television for decades and there's
over 200 credits to his name since he
got to start all the way back in the
late 60s most of his work has been on
the European circuit and the neverending
story was no exception to that rule as
it was filmed primarily in director
Wolfgang Petersen's native Germany
Gerald McRaney stern as Bastian starred
in the neverending story was brief but
the actor has enjoyed a lot more screen
time in his subsequent projects McRaney
had developed quite a small screen
resume before landing the small
supporting role in the movie ante since
continued to thrive on television most
notably he starred in Simon and Simon
for eight seasons before becoming the
titular father figure in the hit sitcom
a major dad he also enjoyed regular
roles on prestige shows such as Deadwood
and house of cards before appearing as
part of the ensemble cast of the NBC
drama this is us in 2016 the childlike
Empress might have relied on the boys in
her life to give her a name but Tammy
Stronach has no such identity crisis the
actress had no screen experience to
speak of when she nabbed the role and
she explained to slash film it was
actually something of a fluke that she
was offered the movie in the first place
although she's had a few other credits
since Stroh knacks current occupation
and passion as professional dancing she
studied dance in college and graduate
school and now runs her own company in
New York her decision to pursue a mostly
non Hollywood Life was intentional she
told the sights I made a decision that I
would throw myself into dance and that
if I really missed acting I would return
to it as an adult but I was in charge of
my life and there wasn't upsetting my
parents who both had really active full
careers and couldn't just give over all
that time to pursue being my manager so
that's what I did and I ended up dancing
for 20 years professionally in New York
you never see his face but what about
the guy who did foul cause voice the
voice actor responsible for most of the
neverending stories most memorable
non-human characters including Falkor
and the rockbiter was alan oppenheimer
who's had an illustrious career in front
of the mic and the camera his on-screen
appearances include an Emmy nominated
guest role on Murphy Brown but you
probably know him best as the voice of
Skeletor from he-man and the Masters of
the Universe
[Music]
as of the making of this video
Oppenheimer is 90 years old but the
voice of old-timer in Toy Story 4 as his
most recent voice credit Thomas Hale who
portrayed the unknowing librarian Carl
Conrad coriander in the neverending
story and this 1990 sequel made a number
of TV and film appearances throughout
the course of his career most notably
his turn is Jim Dickson in Newhart
like several neverending story cast
members Hill is unfortunately no longer
with us having passed away in 2009 at
the age of 81 actor Moses Gunn was
already a critically acclaimed actor
before he suited up as the Empress's
champion Chiron in the neverending story
the actor transcended genre to work in
projects ranging from roots to Little
House on the Prairie to shaft and his
career continued to thrive until he
passed away in 1993 at the age of 64 by
the time Sidney Bromley starred as a
punchy gnome scientist in work and
helped to try you pass through the
riddle game to reach the southern Oracle
he was already four decades into his
career the actor who'd previously
appeared in minor roles in Dragonslayer
and American Werewolf in London and many
many other films and TV shows would
count the neverending story as one of
his final film projects Bromley passed
away in 1987 at the age of 78
ergo the other cantankerous gnome who
helps guide our tre you on his journey
was played by Patricia Hayes a prolific
British actress had been working in the
business for almost 50 years prior to
making the movie her notable credits
included a Fish Called Wanda willow
until death do us part Hayes passed away
in 1998 at the age of 88 check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and TV shows are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and at the Belle so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]